I mean Zhang I'm professor in UC Santa
Barbara today I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about our recent work privacy
amplification and drainie differential
privacy okay so this is joint work with
Borja and Shiva I believe is they are
there they're both here so so so what
I'm not gonna do so I'm gonna first give
a little bit of a historical view about
this problem and motivate like why why
the heck we care about really
differential privacy and purpose
amplification by subsampling in this
setting and then I'm gonna talk a talk
about our results on what can we say
about the subsampled mechanisms under
the framework of really differential
piracy I'm gonna then provide a number
of experiments to illustrate why this is
useful why this is something that you
really wanted to do in practice to save
privacy budget or to squeeze the last
bit of accuracy out of your your your
system and since this is a Simon's
Institute workshop I'm also going to be
talking about proofs hopefully some of
the ideas in the proof and some of the
things that that we we're going to might
be useful in other contexts as well and
I'll conclude with open problems and and
maybe talk about a more recent work on
different sampling model that we
recently we recently finished alright so
um first of all since this is a privacy
workshop we every talks start by talking
about the definition that veep's alone
differential privacy so so so this is
one way to look at it
suppose you have two data sets that
differs by just one data point so in
this case you should think about
replacing one of your data points in the
data set with some some somewhere else
and then there is a randomized algorithm
M that's generating the output given
this data set okay so so the log
probability ratio or the density ratio
suppose you can show that it is upper
bounded uniformly for any pair of the
data sets and any any pair of adjacent
data sets and any possible output it's
upper bounded by by a single number
epsilon zoeng how it keeps a long
differential a private so so um so this
is a one number summary of of the
privacy guarantee so we call this
quantity the the privacy lost random
variable and and you can you can make it
to number summary by including another
number Delta so you have epsilon Delta
differential privacy where you are you
allowed to ignore a small probability or
fail here but the thing is that this
epsilon characterization of this privacy
guarantee doesn't have anything to do
with a specific randomized algorithms
that you use so potentially four
different algorithms if you look at the
probability distribution of these
privacy locks random Arabo can
potentially be very different so there
might be something that we can exploit
if we consider a more fine-grained
algorithm specific analysis of
differential privacy so so that's that
that's what a lot of people had done in
the past decade and the most reason one
of the most reason one is a really
differential privacy framework by Ilia
so so instead of using a uniform upper
bound of the privacy laws random
variable like elia defined
this really really divergence measure of
of that you can think about this as some
transformation of the moment-generating
function of of the privacy about random
error okay and for every order of this
ringi divergence alpha you have a
different potentially different
different upper bound here so so in this
talk I'm gonna take a more functional
point of view of reading differential
privacy so whenever I talk about GDP
it's not about a specific alpha and this
corresponding privacy this epsilon value
it is about Epsilon as a function of
alpha okay so this is obviously closely
related to other development in
concentrated differential privacy by
rose Paloma and one son K there are
different variants and the most recent
one also deals with truncation so
there's this generalization of the CDP
framework that works a little bit more
with subsampling I'll talk a little bit
more about that when we get to our
results so so one of the reason why
people should care about 3d P is is that
it is in some sense a natural kind of
divergence measure for dealing with
composition okay so so it composes very
much like the the pure DP so it composes
linearly suppose you have like two
random randomized algorithms and access
the data and and and them together the
the corresponding DP function would be
simply the sum of the reigning DP
function individually okay
this can be a adaptive composition as
well as long adaptive composition
another use case of ring EDP is that
it's closely related to epsilon Delta
differential privacy in a sense that
suppose you just compose this for many
many runs and and after
the fact you decided that you wanna
you're interested to have a
epsilon-delta interpretation of the the
privacy guarantee that's given to you by
this sequence of randomized algorithm
then you choose your favorite Delta or
your favorite epsilon and and and there
are standard ways that you can use the
Te'o bond to concentration in quantity
to calculate the corresponding best
possible flow or the best possible Delta
when when the other parameter is fixed
by the user so comparing to the standard
advanced composition epsilon del Phi
differential privacy the obvious benefit
is that this is much much cleaner
because because you don't have to
specify a particular pair of epsilon I
and Delta parameter for every iteration
and you also do not have to - to - like
you say the kov enough approach to use
more computation to calculate the
supposedly sharply hard sharply complete
optimal composition of lives without a
differential privacy and and at the end
of the day since we're not really
dealing with just to number
characterization of algorithm we can
potentially take into account of
specific properties of each individual
privacy randomized algorithm and come up
with algorithm specific composition that
often gives you an edge over the
standard optimal composition for epsilon
Delta X privacy
so there's an increasing list of
mechanism where we know how to calculate
rainy differential privacy this include
the standard Gaussian mechanism which
the expression is extremely clean and
there are plus mechanism randomized
responses and so on and all these like
although these are complicated looking
but they are very easily evaluatable in
the inner machines so and this gives you
very precise calculations of the riddle
of the Rana divergence there are many
other differential private mechanisms
including anything almost everything
that that's coming from the exponential
family distribution including posterior
sampling and and and other things that
might might come up in a statistical
estimation and learning problems and and
there rain EDP calculations are usually
available in closed form however this is
still not satisfactory considering how
flexible and how powerful this generic
tools that has been developed over the
over the past decade in in the pure and
approximate differential privacy world
for instance I have no idea how I can do
rain DP for the sparse vector technique
it's no idea how I can replicate the
same kind of like explanation mechanism
in general or or the still kind of
selection problem that Cunha will be
talking about next so so suppose we
really think that our DP is a framework
that we'd like to endorse there are a
long way to go before we can fully
convert to RDP and make use of it who to
do the same kind of analytics
calculation algorithm design in the same
way that we've been doing with oops no
any personal doubt a differential
so for sparse vector Alessa forgetting
something is it so
isn't it just composition of some things
that that's this epsilon differentiate
private so couldn't you use that to get
[Music]
it depends on whether you want to it
like they're they're different variants
itself our Spector technique it depends
on whether you also want to output the
output a coordinate so suppose this
everything follows from post-processing
and is a composition of the Laplace
mechanism there right yeah the putative
UDP will imply REEP with with an upper
bound on everything so you can track
that but that's that's possibly not
tight for the particular algorithm that
you used okay so so so one particular
set of techniques that we are going to
be talking about in this talk is called
a subsample randomized algorithms so so
it goes like the following suppose you
have this data set and and you somehow
randomly pick a subset of randomly pick
a subset of this data set and then you
run a randomized always among this to
produce some kind of output so as in
love the day we're only releasing this
output not the the assignment of of
which subset of pick we only release in
the final output to the adversary or to
the to the public well you notice by the
this function composition so you have a
data that's coming you first sample that
and then you pass it through a different
randomized out
so this could be the differential a
private mechanism so so why do we care
so one of the reason is one of the more
common use case for the sub Sam code for
this sub sub simple randomized algorithm
is the following this noisy SGD
algorithm so so for those who are
familiar with machine learning so this
is simply doing gradient this stochastic
gradient descent by first choose a
random mini-batch calculate the
corresponding stochastic gradient clip
the individual stochastic gradient
corresponding to every individual if
necessary at the calibrate the noise
according to that sensitivity so that
you get differential privacy for every
iteration and then you use the ones
composition over the entire course of
training and the events of the day you
get something that's that's that's
pretty good and for the convex case in
particular when this size of the mini
batch is chosen to be one you actually
expectation we cover the information
theoretic limit for for learning the
types of problems and this is also so
work for horse for more than
differential a private deep learning
and it is really the the recent work by
a body at all that performs the rain EDP
analysis actually makes this practical
that actually demonstrates is that you
can train a deep neural network on some
I toy examples like MMS and get a pretty
pretty reasonable accuracy and this is
essentially what what people are doing
like all the time in the back in in
practice as well but the thing is that
the RDP analysis flow for this
subsampled calcium mechanism like it is
really something that you need to to
work out for every mechanism separately
it's not something that that you can
just just assume that you have said you
have this this mechanism and you can you
can already readily calculate the rdp of
the subsampled version of those
algorithms and for this algorithm to
work a subsampling is in fact essential
otherwise you won't be able to compose
nearly as many iterations to get you to
a reasonable solution there are many
potential use cases for subsampling
algorithm design in particular in
machine learning people do bagging
random forests all the time and this
involves sampling the data are sampling
the corresponding coordinates and in in
frequentist statistics people do a
statistical inference was with
bootstrapping with with subsampling
bootstrapping was jackknife and in all
of these cases you perform some kind of
statistical estimation or apply some
function on a randomly chosen subset so
the kind of sub sample mechanism
actually worked really well with with
these type of applications so so so i'm
four people has thought about developing
differentially private algorithms for
for for for this use case
but we do we just have to do this on a
case-by-case basis like can we can we
say something more general and they can
be for instance so suppose instead of
adding Gaussian noise suppose we want to
add Laplace noise or suppose we want to
use randomize responses for randomly
chosen data point do we have to just do
the calculation again for every method
separately and there are a gazillion
many other approaches you can achieve
differential privacy and chances are you
don't want to do it every time you have
to write a new paper about it so in a
setting of epsilon differential privacy
and if some total differential privacy
the answer is that you actually don't so
there's this generic amplification lemma
that that says if this randomized
algorithm satisfies assume Delta
differential privacy is in the
subsampled version of this satisfy
epsilon prime Delta prime differential
privacy with Delta that's just gamma
times the original failure probability
and with epsilon being equal to
something that that looks like this so
just do the mental calculation when this
gamma is somewhat small when this
epsilon is not too big and and you you
can the linearized version of this log
is about about the same so you get on
the order of gamma times epsilon and you
get the corresponding amplification in
sorcery subsampling
so this this was first thing in a work
by by Shiva and and Adam and a few
others and later like this was also used
as a fundamental theoretical tool for
understanding the the problem of
differentially private learning either
for characterizing the learnability or
to characterizing the the rate in
specific learning problems so more
recently like this version of this
substance sampling lemma is actually
it's actually a more more recent I I
think force for sampling with without
replacement and the first time this
appear I think was in in gentleman's
lecture notes and and then like there's
a very interesting a very elaborate
treatment by puja guy also Marco at nips
last year that that says basically for
many different sampling scheme you get
exactly the same same type of bomb and
this is also also optimal so so the
problem about epsilon-delta differential
privacy amplification lemma is
completely resolved so this talk is
about how do we do about the same thing
for the rainy differential privacy can
we come up with a generic amplification
bomb
so that if we input a RDP function
corresponding to the to the mechanism M
can be state analytically was so
corresponding RDP for the subsample
mechanism so if we can do this and we
can handle many different types of
algorithm where we do have the exact RDP
calculation and we have essentially a
new set of very practical tool in our
differential private algorithm algorithm
design box
okay and is so I'd like to mention that
a big part of this work is to actually
get explicit consent and to get a
constant to be as tight as possible so
because just put it in a blanket
statement that in differential privacy
constant actually matters and constant
matters a lot in practice so so so there
are typically two different types of
substance wing that has been considered
a one is called sampling without without
replacement so essentially this is like
you consider a data set of sites in and
you consider the replacement version of
the differential privacy and the other
word this end is public information you
set this parameter m and upq you pick at
random a random subset of size M on the
other hand more typically studied regime
is called poison sampling so in this
case every data point was an independent
Hall
kourin with a certain probability to
decide whether you got included in the
in the data set or not so so the points
on sampling when when this sampling
probability is the same for every data
point is its equivalent to first sample
M from this binomial distribution then
the sample without replacement so it's
like a smoother version of the sampling
sampling without replacement and and
what's what's typical about the second
approach is that it goes really well
with add/remove version of the original
version of differential privacy rather
than I replace one worship so in this
talk I'm gonna focus on sampling without
replacement and only on to the very end
I'll talk a little bit about the Poisson
sampling case and how the kind of
results are we are able to to obtain is
different from something with
without replacement okay
so so first let me try to talk a little
bit about intuition about how how should
we make sense of this problem and and
and and why this problem is it's
challenging it's not ready readily so
solvable using standard technique okay
so so so recall that we have a two-step
procedure we first a subsample finding a
random subset and then say suppose we
use Gaussian noise heading then we add
noise to the course money statistics
calculated using just a subset so so
let's pick a particular X X Prime
okay let's subsample that and find a
particular X Prime and then condition on
that chosen subset this is where this FX
prime is and then you add noise this is
actually something from scallion
distribution suppose you get a different
subset hole then you get you get a
different mean of this of this of the
subsequent noise heading and and and
this is where we are and since this is
subsampling you have accompanied how
many Tory or many centers that you add
noise from so I think of the day you
have many many such Gaussian so as IND
of the day this is essentially a mixture
of Gaussian distribution okay so so the
key idea why amplification is possible
is because it's because when you when
you change your data set from from X to
something that differs by exactly just
one Y row then only on a very small
fraction of these subsets with these
distributions be different so in
particular may be like in this subset
this additional perturbation got
included in the sub sample all the
others are not so then the only
number of such mixture components
actually God got changed so because of
that there are things that we can hope
to do and they are their amplification
in fact that we can hope to to achieve
okay what more generally is besides
noise adding so you can think about this
as just mean of your arbitrary
randomized algorithm and this index be
the chosen index will show themselves
okay so so the main technical result of
our work is an upper bound that says
that if M obeys epsilon R for any
differential privacy for alpha then the
corresponding subsampled version of this
this algorithm satisfied really rainy
differential privacy care and he that
looks like that so this complicated
looking bond is like let's try to parse
it a little bit so you have this 1 over
alpha minus 1 that's coming from the
definition of rainy divergence you have
this mark 1 plus something that that we
also resembles epsilon Delta
amplification results note that the
first term here there there isn't a term
that depends on gamma so - so that term
goes away and you start with gamma
Square and and you start with a
second-order RDP which is about about
the same as isomorphic to the chi-square
distribution and you have something that
supposed camera is small and suppose
this is not not too crazy you have
something that's that's more or less
funded you have a residual term that's
on the order of oh come on come at you
gamma gamma is M over N so it's a
sampling fraction there there is a
there's a lower bound that we can we can
construct that that essentially says
that up to an additive factor and up to
up to a multiplicative factor that that
that's on the order of 1 over 1 minus
gamma to the power of OJ like these two
bound actually
match is a mesh a term by term up to up
to a constant but but that's that's not
really what we want so let's not try to
stare at this bum for too long to try to
make sense of that let's just plot it
that's just for four examples of four
examples of mm let's just plot it and
see how far away this is our lower
bounds are okay so so suppose we plot
the subsample Gaussian mechanisms or any
rrdp function on here so this blue line
describes the upper bound so so it's a
weird new King shape so it starts with a
slow slow increase almost like a linear
increase so by the way this is Lok Lak
plot on the horizontal axis I have the
rdp order alpha on the vertical axis we
have the earth the radius epsilon value
corresponding to that alpha and and we
can see that in this case upper and
lower bounds in this regime they differ
by a fixed constant and and on the other
regime so after this point on phase
transition it becomes much bigger and
then the two bonds are essentially
identical okay just ignore the gaussian
gaussian approximation for now
and and suppose we do this for the
Laplace distribution pass mechanisms and
we get something that's similar well
let's let's take a closer look first so
what does this first chunk me so this is
a chunk when the when the leading term
is one plus and this first term that
depends on gamma square is actually the
largest amount of the everything in the
summation so you end up getting this
this term that's linear that's almost
linear in artha with a little bit of
luck 1 plus its own transformation and
then there's a there's another regime
where like you don't actually get
amplification at all so you end up
getting just the standard epsilon power
file from one single call of this
Gaussian MCing so where does this phase
transition happen so from our bound we
can just read off that it happens
roughly at gamma times alpha star it
happens at alpha star when this equation
is approximately true
okay so for the for the Laplace
mechanism on the right hand side so
first of all we know that from the
epsilon DPS amplification result we know
that it's going to gonna flatten out
eventually okay so this is a
corresponding amplified epsilon
differential privacy that we eventually
reach and before that you you see the
same like linear increase as a function
of Arafah all the way up to say say 10
to the power of three
so so it's interesting to compare this
to two other formalism of trying to deal
with rainy divergence and kind of
characterization for randomized
randomized algorithm so so this includes
like the CVP and the truncated CDP so so
the CDP is basically your you're trying
to use a linear upper bound to to pound
the the kind of RDP function like
throughout throughout the domain so
throughout any alpha and you can see
that that wouldn't work very well
because you have you have a much smaller
linear term render than there is a
southern phase transition there suppose
you want to fit a uniformly linear curve
as an upper bound of the RDP parameter
you end up getting something that grows
much quicker okay and then he CDP is
something that's that's more recent so
so you basically ignore the part when
alpha reaches the threshold and and you
set a threshold as part of the parameter
of this truncated CDP and that gives you
a more precise cut calculation but it's
also not exactly the same as RDP because
it is a linear upper bound and as we
know the kind of one that we're getting
is log 1 plus epsilon type yeah for 4 e
to the power 0 minus 1 is somewhat
somewhat big and gamma is somewhat small
and then this linear bound will give you
something that's a good approximation
so so so this kind of found an RDP allow
us to come up with data structure which
we call analytic moment content so this
is an extension of our body at also more
mobile content so so so users can
literally just keep track of everything
that they've done to the data set and
then add the corresponding RDP
parameters to this data structure and
this is going to keep track for
everything that has happened so far and
and some some kind of algorithm can be
subsampled and and this is gonna just
take into everything into account at the
same time and then at the end of the day
the user will only have to specify what
was their favorite to Delta and then the
data structure is going to calculate the
corresponding epsilon therapy half so so
this in my opinion it allows us to
automatically calculate the DPS
differential privacy is privacy laws for
very complex algorithms that people
might think of so and this enables our
DP analysis for those who do not want to
learn and learn the math and and from
our discussion throughout the workshop I
think this is one of the very important
problems that that we should really
think about how to help the
practitioners now what what is different
about this the most accountant that's
presented okay so so so the main
differences have to do with how how do
we deal with subsampling first of all
with this we can deal with subsample
laplace we can deal with sub-sample
other mechanisms but but in in your body
at all I guess they can only deal with a
subsample gaussian and secondly we keep
track of everything at in analytical
form so you implement a lambda function
you keep track of that lambda function
you check whether this length
has appeared before in a hash table so
you don't have to to save that for every
every time you come host so so so this
is just a little bit more more more
general yeah but the idea comes directly
from a body at all
okay so so suppose we just just plug
this into the this is the setting we
need to compose over many many sub
simple mechanisms here are the kind of
results that we're getting so the way so
so on both these two plots on the Left
I'm doing composing over many many sub
sample Gaussian down on the right I'm
composing over many many sub sample
Gaussian which this is much smaller
noise noise level so so I'm comparing
with with two baselines the the purple
line is just a naive composition where
we simply add up epsilon deltas and this
green line is something that's slightly
more complicated so so it is a damask
composition and the way we calculate
that is to first calculate the epsilon
delta by choosing a delta parameter of
the base mechanism we use the epsilon
delta amplification lemma to get a sub
sampled version and then we plug that
into the the optimal composition by by
Cairo's at all at the end of the day we
also optimize over the initial doubt has
a we choose so that we can get as small
as possible epsilon for the for the
desired Delta which is equal to 10 to
the power of minus 8 okay so this is
really like the the best that we can do
with using just epsilon Delta
differential privacy okay so as we can
see as we keep composing over the number
of runs of subsample calcium mechanisms
this is significantly bigger like my
order of magnitudes and
our upper bound and a little bit even
even bigger than the lower bound and and
and I suppose we just add a much smaller
amount of noise for every base mechanism
then then the gap becomes more more
drastic okay so so so the pay will be
like for the choice of Delta and epsilon
combinations it doesn't actually for any
parameter it doesn't actually give us
the right kind of deep
for for this ascetic but what what's
curious is is why do we see this
flattening curve here so so in certain
regimes when we do not compost enough
when we actually want a very small
epsilon from the epsilon Delta
differential privacy then then the rainy
DP framework is actually significantly
outperformed by the more naive approach
of simply adding up if small and out
okay so the this is because this is
because in that setting thanks to this
phase transition of this Gaussian RDP so
throughout these the optimum our facade
that got chosen to calculate the season
1 Delta is actually picked at that kinky
point so also beyond that you you're not
able to significantly drives the epsilon
down by by a large margin so that that's
why RDP like it's really helpful when
you when you compose over many many runs
of a composition but but not not always
it's not always gonna come out perform
the baseline suppose we do subsample
Laplace well we get something that is
similar although we get rid of that
artifact because the Laplace has has an
upper bound as are far goes to infinity
that's why we get something that looks
much better here and you would think
that the epsilon Delta or is epsilon DP
calculation for the Laplace mechanism is
already like very tight and very precise
but you still get some kind of a
constant improvement by applying the
moment moments account
this is with a certain choice of life
this is with us with a fix of Delta know
so so the so for every single point like
this you actually choose the best alpha
who gives you the smallest possibly okay
all right so so so so I'll spend the
remainder of the time talking about
proofs so I'll go a little bit quicker
because because I'm running out of time
so so the idea of the proof is true is
to actually take the rate DP to a
different domain how the ternary Pearson
rushed a divergence domain and we define
something called a ternary Pearson much
that I have different different
differential privacy so this is
something that only comes up due to
technical reasons so so so so don't
think about this as a brand new privacy
definition but the good thing about this
is that in this domain it is much easier
to talk about amplification so you get
an extremely clean amplification lemma
for this kind of definition of
differential piracy so so what we did
was to to convert this RDP for this
composed mechanism to its corresponding
ternary Pearson much a divergence
version of the definition amplify that
and then use the RDP of the base
mechanism to upper bound the the the
ternary Pearson much the divergence of
the of the basic mechanism so that's
that that's a big picture how the proof
works so a short detour to the to the
divergences people should be familiar
with this you have greenie divergence
and for different choices of Arafah you
get something that you're familiar with
you get Hellinger distance you can tell
that virgins when you take our pal at
the limit two to one and and you get
something that's very similar to to
chi-square divergence when you take
alpha equals to two and in general where
you have a convex function f you can
define your divergence like like that
and and what what is Pearson marginal
divergence you can think about it as a
generalization of the chi-square
divergence by increasing the power to an
arbitrary integer L and since this is
not always a divergence because when all
is well now is an odd number
so this is not really a convex function
so so people also define the absolute
version of the Pearson R a heterogeneous
okay so that's that's what what we're
going to be using and and is it's an
interesting connection to the to the
privacy random variable because suppose
you put the moment generating function
of the privacy random variable here if
you take derivatives of
arthas outer and assign that to zero you
recover the moments of the privacy
random variable but suppose you take the
discrete derivative here you get a
linearized version of this you get the
moment of the linearized version of the
privacy what's random variable so so so
this is how a ternary version of the Chi
absolute value are for divergence is
defined so instead of having just two
distributions so now we have three
distributions in this divergence measure
so this is not typical this is again
something that comes out of our analysis
quite naturally so so and these
distributions are assumed to be mutually
adjacent they're coming from mutually
adjacent datasets for instance in this
case all the other people in this
dataset are the same except for the for
the last one okay but we have we have
three of them and this is implied by the
definition of mutual adjacency because
if you require them to be adjacent by a
distance function of one then this
implies that for these three
distributions the coordinates or the the
location where you make that change
needs to be identical otherwise you have
you have a distance of two and when you
take the supremum over all possible data
sets you get the corresponding
destination of of a Pearson much that
differential privacy we just for
normalization purposes we take 1 over R
power here okay and similarly we can
also define the binary version of of
these and and these are more or less
equivalent the ternary or the binary
version of this is tptp measure
they are bounded from above and below by
a constant factor and and and this
proposition shows that this notion of
privacy is actually very natural to talk
about subsampling okay suppose M obeys
this kasaya ternary differential privacy
then the corresponding compose mechanism
simply obey this but with just a
constant multiplication to this function
by the sampling probability so this is
saying that well it is like just like
the the Rini differential privacy is
natural for composition the verse the
Pearson burst a divergence is really
natural for talking about substantive
and if this part of the proof but the
idea is to condition on two events
whether the the perturbation is included
in the data set or not included in the
data set this these are purely on the
index domain and and as we said for all
the three distributions the
corresponding index of that perturbation
are the same so we can do this kind of
calculation and then gain an additional
camera to the J here and I note that the
like all these quantities are still
mixture distributions so we have to
somehow deal with that so so the idea is
that we need to match them in twos in to
triplets by introducing additional
smoothing so that we can match them in
to triplets and in every one of those
settings we can upper bound these with
just Pierce and watch that divergence of
the basement and the second step would
be to bound the RDP with it
with with this so so this is very simple
so you just add one and subtract one and
then you apply binomial expansion and
you end up getting something that that's
that's in the form of the binary
operation marginal divergence and then
you can upper bound the the binary way
to the ternary since you are maximizing
where more things so you can always
always do this and then you apply the
natural
sampling proposition in the previous
slide you get something like that
okay and the last step this is a little
bit messy so so so so now that you
express everything in in a form of this
Chi to the power of alpha differential
privacy and then you have to convert
everything back to to trainee diversions
so we have multiple ways of dealing with
that and and once you substitute all
these lemmas and all these different
calculations and then take the the
minimum of all of them you are not
getting the serum that we we started
with okay so so the lower bound is is
much easier so so this is nothing
information theoretical you basically
need to construct one particular dataset
and and for that data set for that is a
data set all the data points are
repeated from the first one to n minus
one and so suppose you take an arbitrary
subset that they matches exactly so the
mixtures will have the identical Center
and all the mixer components most of the
mixer components will have either will
be identically distributed so that that
gives you more or less matching lower
bound so but there's still this constant
that's really troublesome like how how
can we deal with this additional
constant factor
like I said constant can be really
important for ever playing differential
piracy and can be can be somehow closes
a little bit more so so the conclusion
is that for subsampling without
replacement there are something we can
do but we need additional assumptions on
this mechanism which I'm gonna skip but
for this alternative sampling scheme
called poison sampling and we can
actually obtain a much more precise
result so so this is essentially just a
lower bound that we were looking at and
that lower bound also applies to the
post post on sampling scheme the only
difference is that there is a factor of
three yeah and this factor of three can
be first of all this is on a lower order
term and
family this factor of Syria can be
removed suppose we can checks as the
alts other non absolute version of the
Pearson R divergence are always greater
than zero which we use a different
argument for caching and the Laplace
mechanism and we show that it's actually
the case so so now we have an exact
bound for the poison subsampling version
of of caution and Laplace mechanism same
thing again Suu the the standard one
that's at your familiars you pick a one
data point independently with
probability gamma now yo is equivalent
to take the okay you include each
independently weights probability come
yeah this was my work with my student
reaching so you may wonder whether this
kind of tablet calculation can be done
for any mechanism but unfortunately the
answer is no so so from this example by
Newton knock even within the exponential
family suppose you compare two Poisson
distributions and the parameters of the
Poisson distribution coming from two
adjacent datasets and then you get these
this highly negative all also other
appears in much divergences which
essentially gives you a bigger upper
bound than the one that that we've seen
so this really needs to be dependent but
in the worst case you actually get a
constant factor just a factor of cerium
below all the time
okay so that concludes a talk
and I guess open problems are how do we
close a constant gap in both settings
and and how do we exploit the randomness
from the data so if you think about it
like this kind of thing a very similar
to kernel density estimation so chances
are suppose they are in the inherent
randomness from the data and with this
additional smoothing factor from the
additional added noise that we're having
and then we can hope to obtain like more
privacy when the data is highly Mary
right thank you
[Applause]
do you have an example of a mechanism
where the generic epsilon2 parameter we
private conversion to RTE as a large
constant factor overhead over some
specific analysis so if I forget that I
can once mechanism and I just say okay
it's half epsilon over epsilon square
and also cap it private the big gap
between the RTP curves is actually not
very big yeah so so so I guess a
subsample of plants making ism is an
example of that but but suppose you want
pure DPS and you're not getting anything
you're not not getting anything so so
the kind of results that you get an
advantage over the course of composition
is only for for you tomorrow
so we'll never goes to infinity the the
calculation of the pure DP is tight and
the amplification lemma is also tight so
so this is just a more refined way of
dealing with the cases when you actually
don't want perfect pure pure
differential pairs
let's take a short break